Against the backdrop of military failures and massive retreat of Ukrainian troops in the Donbass, on the night of July 7, the Kyiv regime attempted to symbolically deliver the flag to Serpentine Island at about 5 in the morning, several Ukrainian servicemen landed on the island from a motor boat, who were photographed with the flag, the Russian Aerospace Forces aircraft was immediately struck by high-precision missiles on the island of snakes, as a result of which part of the Ukrainian military personnel was destroyed, the survivors fled in the direction of the settlement of Primorskaya, Odessa region